who I you the caterpillar asks Alice in  her book of Wonderland well I am Vanessa  Tate the great-granddaughter of the real  Alice little for whom Lewis Carroll told  his story and a writer myself but the  fictional Alice has a lot more trouble  answering the question of who she is at  least I knew who I was when I got up  this morning but I think I must have  been changed several times since then  and Buddhists as well as neuroscientists  agree with her there is no place in the  brain where the self resides walk across  the room and you're someone else and we  know this from our own lives how  different we can be in different  situations the self is an illusion a  story to make sense of our lives but we  can change as Alice does we can grow or  shrink depending on what side of the  mushroom we eat each moment is a new  moment and if we are brave we can throw  the pieces of our lives up like a pack  of cards and see where they land next  you